s'il faut apprendre la vérité m quitte
c'est sûr je suis tombé sur une mention
joffo à la prendra
pourquoi j'ai créé cette société à la
con sérieux
parce que les gens sont morts les gens
parlent zoulou garde ces petits vieux
là-bas amoureux comme au premier jour
je crois qu'ils ont besoin de nous
animé par lui
salut le making of et où soit personnage
c'est moi c'est la foudre je m'appelle
romain paul eluard marco garcia du clan
des garcia je suis monsieur gaudin se
fait maurice sim tiens c'est vrai que
c'est une grande chance d'avoir d'avoir
autant de gaz dans le film de kad merad
michèle laroque norman nawel matanie
vincent des agneaux philippe duquesne
on a aussi la fouine on a duré star on à
chantal ladesou tout s'est fait très
facilement c'est à dire que chaque
personne qui nous enjoint c'était ça
chauffe et sont très fluides c'était
c'est ce fait même très très simplement
je sais pas peut-être qu'ils aimaient
bien les balles et les films qu'on avait
fait avant c'est pour ça que ça a rendu
les choses faciles il est certain qu'on
avait rencontré aussi depuis depuis des
listings qui ont été très bien entendu
par tous et ajoutant et c'est tout ce
que je souhaite
pourquoi parce que j'ai vu que mes
parties monsieur voulait savoir quelle
était la surprise aujourd'hui jour
exceptionnel on a la chance d'avoir un
acteur qui a fait 84 millions d'entrées
au cinéma c'est lui et moi c'est lui
ouais salut qu'à 4 mais rate sur le film
en a en un un coup de fil c'est ça c'est
fait donc dans le film je suis monsieur
gaudin parce que je couvre lui présente
son personnage je me godest où je sais
même pas lu le scénario
c'est quoi son métier
macstories personnage il n'a pas ici
n'était pas confiant ça aussi c'est sale
c'est ça l'amour du métier en soi r moi
ça va elle est très proche son mât lire
d'un copain
elle est le deuxième français revient
demain donne donc les bars allez salut
très fier de l'avoir rencontré guy
compris il ya toujours les bouley un
constat amer aju
google
je veux savoir philippe dit quoi
mais dès qu il
une crotte de nez
une crotte de nez on a aussi perdu dans
la vie de pierre du nom qui fait une
apparition attention à vous de le
retrouver d'un film eva il joue très
bien dans tout en finesse tout en
sobriété et su que les façons texte
c'est con c'est lui qui l'a écrit
j'improvise beaucoup c'est à vous que je
vous sers à temps je t'ai pas dit action
action
on a la chance d'avoir un tas de guest
on à mon père le beau père de laurent
même coupé
[Musique]
ok ce sens une faction de mahmoud guinea
guiding tu peux te sort un temps que
tout le monde s'y colle donc on a un tas
d'artistes non mais de façade artistique
il va être bien ce qui gonfle quart
d'heure va sortir en dvd